foreign
I'm doing day wave like normal normal
day day Wave by the way check it out day
wave on Rumble just kidding biggest news
story of the century Don lemon's house
what
ground everybody loves him almost
trended
except for one thing
and like I tweeted out my top comment I
have one of the top comments are almost
on Don lemon's tweet about leaving
dude Bruce brought this up before the
show he goes how [__] mad do you
ought to be if you're Don Lemon that
even the day you get fired and there
would be you should release some Fanfare
and some farewells and some trending
stuff and he's overshadowed again
Rick Olson
oh no Don Lemon and by the way dick Matt
let's do this let's do this in disorder
because it is the best way to do it
because
[Music]
um
Don Lemon tweeted out and Dick Masterson
pointed out why he typed this out on
notepad and just screenshotted it I'll
never know
such a stupid way you know you pay for
Twitter blue you can do the longer
tweets thank you you could you could do
as long as you want anyway well this is
a woman thing and honestly I I gotta say
gay guys are women gay guys are women
yes but usually women do all four
squares I'll give it to Don Lemon at
least he only did one square I was
informed this morning by my agent that
I've been terminated by CNN I'm stunned
after 17 years at CNN I would have
thought that someone in management would
have had the decency to tell me directly
well that guy's not there anymore at no
time was I even given an indication that
it would not be able to continue to do
work uh the work that I have loved at
the network it is clear that there are
some larger issues at play with that
said I want to thank my colleagues and
the many teams I've worked with for an
incredible run they are the leave him at
the same teams yeah
Don Lemon is now gone from CNN and by
the way just just to point out I'm very
proud of my one of the top comments now
like usual Tucker beat you by one hour
so here's the thing an hour before he
tweeted this
oh no
and this this is my favorite way thank
you Marsh for sending me because this is
the way that most people that were
watching it live just were shocked
here's Dan bongino who just also
recently left Fox News I saw this clip
and I was like this was a legit
derailment of this man's show like yeah
this [__] him all up
here it is
folks I gotta tell you we got like a
actual Goosebumps here
there are very rare moments in the show
where I have to stop the show uh
completely especially in a live chat
let's stop the show but
apparently Tucker Carlson and fox are
done
what
do you even know why even the producer
who's never on my damn boat Universe
pretty tight ship was like what
that's what I mean this was a total
derailment and you can't blame them of
course but it's just so funny he's like
ah usually what background everybody's
like Jesus I'm reading it right here
then it's just broke I mean it's the
benefit of a live show
I'm like son
I'm stunned I don't even know what to
say right now I'm like I don't even know
I'm gonna get back to that segment um
Fox News and Tucker Carlson agreed to
parways
we thank him for his service his last
program was Friday April 21st that's
never that's never a good parting by the
way when they come out and go yeah his
last show is with the one we didn't know
was last show it's never a good ending
what
wow I mean I got six texts here from
people
holy Moses
I didn't even get the comment it's free
this frigates she's got a huge path I
guess he's like bringing the reliever
I don't even know what to say I I think
I think it should be pointed out
as Dan bongino ever been a man who had
trouble coming up with Nerds if anything
he never shuts up that's what I mean
I've never seen him not be able to
verbalize something and he's like
ah
nothing
nobody well by the way someone pointed
out no Pro of course there's no farewell
show I have a feeling Don Lemon was
fired I think Tucker quit
I don't think Fox fired him now look we
don't know by the way what we're about
to do is called speculating wildly
because that's the only thing we could
do at this point so to speculate wildly
at least we admitted unlike the regular
news yeah we have no inside knowledge we
have no [__] clue we are wildly
speculating we are speculating as
[__] wildly as you can imagine but
the Dominion thing which is a settlement
happened late last week where Fox News
settled with the Dominion voting
machines for a tune of 730 million
dollars
um now my theory whether it's true or
not I don't know but my theory and you
guys tell me what you think I'd love to
hear what the chat has to say but my
theory is
um
something in that settlement there was
some sort of gag order or something
where Fox News was not allowed to talk
about
Dominion voting machines and Tucker was
like and there probably was maybe some
sort of memo that went out to everybody
going like you're not allowed to because
I was like [__] you I'm leaving then
don't tell me what to say and leave and
left
some other people are saying that there
was that Ray Epps thing that happened on
60 Minutes this weekend that was
infuriating and also hilarious yeah I
mean it was a mixture of both I was mad
but it was also really funny watching
them try to run interference for a
literal Federal
Insurgent yeah it is it is hilarious but
we we have we have that we have some
clips of that that we're going to play
as well God what a weekend it's been
yeah we have some clips of that we're
gonna play as well but but before before
we even get to the right I wonder if
you're I don't know
this and I think he was probably like no
[__] you man because honestly if you let
me on the air it's going to be the first
thing I talk about yeah and then the
rayapps thing is going to be the second
thing
but you know what and it's funny because
about a year ago I go a year and a half
ago
we we even said something like man you
know we love what [__] we love we love
what [__] Tucker's doing it's in this
and that but the arc I think it's like
but you know
he's still working for the media like
you know and then he is he gonna and
then he did it the [__] son of a
[__] goes [__] you I'm leaving which is
you got to admit it's a baller move but
that being said Fox News just lost 930
million and Counting it's ticking right
now market cap because of this that was
her highest rated show Who you gonna
[__] put on there Tyrus like who
you're replacing with Tulsi gabbard I
got news for you first off Tulsi gabbard
cannot do a show she's just a tele
retail prompters poorly cat Temple
no cat tip stop I know it's your PNF and
it's confusing okay very annoying can
cats eat a sandwich he was like 101
pounds did she get married and change
that last name or if she's already
married the force that guy and get rid
of that last name yeah fine cat Epstein
sounds better there you go so that's the
Jewish name
um yeah I know
pretty common one
um it's very common
um just [__] like yes I'm pink
because not because the white balance is
off I went to the beach the as we talked
about a couple weeks ago the
afro-cubating of Royce is beginning and
as the weeks go on you will see me get
darker and darker it has begun versus
afro-latino transformation is happening
it has begun I'm doing the reverse Sami
Sosa they're like werewolves these
people
that's except we take your silver so we
uh what was I saying oh so I think it's
a Dominion thing I really believe that I
mean that could
the only thing I could see but well if I
work for rumble right now I'm stalking
this man trying to get him to at least
have a dinner with us and right now I'm
looking at all those conference rooms in
Rumble and I'm going somebody's name is
getting scraped off some glass in here
somebody's losing an office
I mean I mean I'm sorry Dave Rubin but
we're gonna have to move you down to the
uh there's a booth at a Chili's I can
set you up with
um I was saying quiet one though it's
like the one where they do the private
events
I I was I was I was saying this when it
happened but because I wouldn't happen
live on on when I was watching on daily
but but it's what is
a couple things
where did what does he what does he do
next probably go go solo he doesn't
really need anybody you know well they
got an idea in the chat we should offer
him third mic
would just be the straight man
I guess
I guess he'd be okay I don't know if
he's good on his feet might be our third
Mike tuck you want to be our Jim Norton
oh God could you imagine yeah we want to
be Jim Jimmy Norton
uh Royce you have the veiny skin of a
newborn baby yes
um
I don't know I I'm probably gonna he's
not gonna go to Newsmax please okay I
don't want to say that because I don't
know what's happening do not go to
newsmans don't go to the news man please
don't go that's worse than Fox I think
it's beneath him I don't think he'll do
that don't get a news mix he's not he's
not Como he doesn't need to do that oh
yeah you can get some free agent stuff
made
Tucker and Chris Cuomo the interview I
can't wait for it if I'm Tucker because
you can't patent the words free agent if
I'm Tucker I make free agent gear and
start selling it as well as well same
way sure you can't trademark the phrase
of course not if I'm talking I'm
reaching out to Chris Cuomo right now
have me on yeah because what are you
gonna do say no
it's the biggest [__] show of your
career you're gonna say no yeah I mean
do you think
right now currently what I heard is
they're just going to have a rotating
cast of people that are going to be
feeling this time so it's going to suck
got it no I know but I mean hear me out
get Neil Cavuto bring them in bring Neil
out of retirement hear me out
Shepard Smith bring them back Shep Smith
chef Smith we do it hey what's Combs
doing oh he's dead
hear me out
both fired Don Lemon took across into a
new Hannity and combs Tucker and the
lemon party I know I think we all work
on the name a little bit but okay
talking at the lemon party that's even
worse you somehow made it worse okay I
don't know I'm just trying to work I'm
working this I'm let's work it out we
could do this I'm telling you Don Lemon
got fired because he's a [__] he's
he's a diva [__] that's why Don Lemon
left because he was screaming at 40 year
old women that worked with him right in
their face yes
and it's weird too because when Don
Lemon found out about uh uh his firing
he didn't even look surprised at all
turns out it's from all the Botox he
can't look surprised yeah but somebody
said this there's a my I was telling
this before the show to Marsh but
there's a much bigger chance we're going
to get the Tucker Carlson finding
interview like Alex Jones and stuff
because I know he's wanted to do that he
just [__] a lot on Fox news but
um I think that you'll get uh more of a
I don't know I mean unleashes you think
he's gonna go full School
no I mean I think he's gonna be a little
bit more
loose but I don't think he's not he's
not gonna go full hear me out or
anything
back to the bow tie
yeah bring the boats up I think you go
back bow tie why not it's a good look
it's respectable